let's go next to Ricky from Charlotte
Ricky from Charlotte welcome to the
program
hey David uh I just uh joined the call
log so I didn't hear the earlier
questions but has anyone already asked
about the the fetterman nas debate well
it what was brought up the only thing
that's been brought up so far about Oz
fetterman earlier this week was that the
left just seems to have higher standards
for candidates sometimes to our own uh
deficit that that was really the only
angle so far
okay well I guess the the main thing I
was getting at was Hal was trying to get
an idea of how damaging you think this
could be for fetterman
um and I I know that like it probably
remains to be seen I was trying to like
look at other campaigns that have had
like you know things that in theory
should have been disastrous but some
candidates still ended up performing
better yeah
um I don't know if you uh saw back in
2018 there was a
um there's a famous brothel owner in
Nevada who was running for election he
was like a big friend of uh Donald Trump
I remember that I don't remember the
guy's name but I remember Dennis
he died he died two weeks before his
election and he still won by like a two
to one margin right
um and so you know I feel like you know
dying has got to be like worse than like
just having
um
so here's my sense of this you're right
I don't know what the effect is going to
be yet the the issue what what really is
disappointing about this is
fetterman's not having a cognitive issue
it was very clear during the debate
he knew Oz's positions on things
he knew uh what Oz had said about
different things he was having an issue
converting thoughts into speech and it's
not as though this would in any way
limit his ability to be a senator his
doctors have cleared him for full
senatorial Duty and because it's so
close it's a one point right now with
the polling we have it's 1.3 points by
which fetterman is winning
you may end up with Senator Oz because
fetterman had a stroke and that's just
so disturbing
so you think there are probably some
enough undecided left that would be
willing to flip their vote I'm not
saying there are I'm not saying there
are but I'm saying it's so close that
even if the number is really small
it could flip the election I don't think
it's a large number of people it's just
so close
okay and I guess so the last thing on
this is uh what do you think fetterman
could do from here like the last two
weeks to turn this around I don't think
there's anything I think it's just it's
the ground game and I don't I don't know
that fetterman publicly doing stuff is
what he needs I think it's just he's got
to have a better ground game get out the
vote
put on repeat the fact that Oz said
local politicians should be involved in
making decisions about abortions and
hope that that is enough
do you think what if you did like a
press conference with like a physician
or something like that and and he was
able to speak more clearly or the yeah
it's got to go really well and so he's
got to be sure it's going to go so well
that it will convince people and I just
don't know I just don't know yeah
okay yeah
um it's a frustrating situation I agree
with you yeah okay cool all right well
thanks for taking my call me all right
thanks very much there's Ricky from
Charlotte raising a very important
questions that's for sure let's go to
Ann in Wisconsin another uh critical
state in this election and welcome to
the program
hi
um glad that I got through
um
so
I am looking at the macro picture of
kind of American politics right now and
I am kind of scared
of the overall
let's say Nazi iization
of the Republican party
and I think you've talked about it and
the increasing anti-Semitism yes
that is taking over and from my
perspective
being one of those letters in the LGBT
it is terrifying because I think what
gets overlooked
is that the Nazis are the reason that
um our Research into
um
LGBT health is not where it should be we
are years and years behind because
um one of the Pioneers I believe his
name is hirschfeldt
um all of his research was burned by the
Nazis
so
um
and so it it and this is relevant
because the question of the Supreme
Court overturning
gay marriage is kind of up in the air
right now yes and to me this just
screams holy [ __ ] we're going down Nazi
land
and so it's horrified it would be better
if you didn't swear because we have to
bleep that I also did you have a
question today Anne yes
yes
um do you have an overall
um
sense that that's the direction
that we're going
or do you think that's a fringe do you
think that's going to become a majority
of the party majority I don't know but
it's been made abundantly clear
that they're not stopping with their
Victory on Roe v Wade you don't have
your biggest Victory and then say I'm
done I mean okay Michael Jordan retired
at the top after three but then he came
back and he won some more and then you
know okay the point is it's they're not
going to just call it quits after one of
their biggest victories in decades
they've said they believe that the gay
marriage decision was wrongly decided in
the same way that they believe Roe v
Wade was wrongly decided so they're
coming for it the question is will they
succeed
and I don't know the answer to that one
thing that scares me Anne is that if you
look at recent right-wing in-person
events like for example CPAC a few
months ago the biggest Applause lines
were the anti-lgbt
um comments and it happened with Ted
Cruz on pronouns and it happened with
Trump and so it does seem that there is
a Resurgence of anti-lgbt sentiment
within the Republican Party
right and
my take on that and I don't know if you
agree is that none of them care about
that it's just Mass hysteria who doesn't
care in what sense
they don't I don't think they really
care about the gay marriage or the the
pronouns oh I I think they do but I
think they care about it
more broadly about what they feel it
means for the direction of the country
and less about individual LGBT people
that I would agree with okay because I
think I I don't know I just think are
they going to use this kind of
rhetoric because I I honestly think that
they're going to go Nazi
just flat out
well I I don't know let's hope that
doesn't happen but in the in the
immediate we have some very important
votes coming up just two weeks from now
so I know you'll be voting Anne and I
really appreciate the call
all right thank you so much for having
me on sorry for the swears no problem
very very important stuff and I
appreciate that